if we truly have an outage it is
Nationwide that lasts nine months EMP
commission which is a commission that
was mandated by U.S Congress and it has
much more Authority and better funding
than a congressional committee they
found that as many as 90 percent of
Americans would die so it really becomes
almost zombie apocalypse
that's right if the power went out in
America for just nine months ninety
percent of the population would die
and you might be thinking to yourself
well good thing that has a very low
chance of happening right but
unfortunately you would be wrong because
if you wanted to send America back to
the Stone Age all you'd have to do is
take out nine key substations and the US
would go into a total blackout they
ended up running a study and they found
that if there were as few as nine
critical substations were taken out you
know just key nodes it could cause the
power to go out Nationwide in the United
States nine substations that's right
just nine substation Transformers and
you will send America into absolute
chaos and here's the thing about these
substation Transformers how long would
it take just to replace one of these
gigantic Transformers and the
documentary you guys talk about it you
show how big these Transformers are I
mean they would have to remove stop
lights maybe even remove some overpasses
I mean this is no this isn't just a
delivery of a of 6x6 box generator this
is a I mean these Transformers are the
size of buildings right exactly there
are hundreds of tons each and therefore
how long would it take if there were
three or four if they they could
probably get it done in a month or so
but if there are 50 or 200 then we're
we're talking about chaos we're talking
about extreme chaos
and if the
if these important to our very survival
one would think that they would be
guarded 24 7 right but no they're not
drive to your local substation right now
and you'll see that the only protection
these things have is a measly barbed
wire fence so you can bet that our
enemies have our delicate power grid in
their crosshairs in fact as you're about
to see these attacks have already been
happening this is not calm the Russians
are already in the grid this is not a
threat this is happening now we are
under attack
stay dangerous and just and the coming
collapse of the US power grid
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
grid is in shambles these utility
companies are currently rolling in tens
of billions of dollars and if you have a
business that ships stuff then you have
to know about shipstation shipstation is
the shipping software that Joe Rogan's
on it brand uses and it's been a
complete game changer for their business
it's allowed them to streamline their
shipping so much that they're able to
ship out over 500 orders an hour which
would have been pretty much impossible
without ship station so if ship station
is good enough for Joe Rogan it's
probably good enough for your brand as
well that's because shipstation is the
fastest most affordable way to ship
products to your customers all you got
to do is import your orders from all
your selling channels then you can
accelerate your shipping with other
streamlining tools while being able to
access shipping discounts of up to 84
and once you ship out an order
shipstation will instantly update the
tracking information to the selling
Channel and the customer they've got
over 130 000 Merchants using shipstation
right now to save time and drive revenue
and the best part is that you can try it
out for free for 60 days before
committing all you got to do is go to
shipstation.com
link below to get your free 60-day trial
that's two months of faster stress-free
shipping at shipstation.com with the
link below thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
foreign
a.m on April 16 2023 or you know just
three months ago from the time of
recording this video it was at this time
when residents near a San Jose
substation woke up to the sound of
gunshots ringing through the nights
for a full minutes gunmen opened fire on
a Pacific Gas and Electric substation
with over a hundred rifle rounds so it
seems that eight or nine terrorists were
utilized in AK-47s or AR-15s and
shooting out you know the cooling you
know facility for these Transformers
unfortunately police got there they
disappeared into the night they've never
solved you know who this was
unfortunately
we were able to divert power such that
it did not cause a massive outage in
Silicon Valley but it was frankly a
wake-up call and frankly it was hidden
for about a year until the Wall Street
Journal ran the story a year later it
was hidden yes the powers of B did not
want the American public to understand
that there might be Terror is out there
taking out a substation it's also
possible that they didn't want this to
create you know metoo attacks you know
other people saying oh we can do this
and therefore you know potentially our
powers would be have some reasons for
you and I both know you know our
authorities don't tell us the truth all
the time this this interview is from the
Sean Ryan Show by the way Sean does some
of the best interviews on the internet
on par with Joe Rogan in my opinion I'm
a big fan and I highly recommend you
guys subscribe to his Channel with the
link below and the single
unsophisticated attack carried out by
just a few guys brought down 17
substation Transformers and cost around
15 million dollars in Damages but that's
not what was shocking what was really
terrifying is that they never got caught
yes these attackers are still roaming
around two this day in hindsight the
residents felt that yes these
substations should obviously be
protected better but hindsight is 2020
and the truth is that every single one
of these vital substations around
America are just as vulnerable to an
attack like this right now as we speak
and indeed the attacks are happening you
just don't hear about it according to
the Department of energy physical
attacks on the grid Rose by 77 in 2022.
77 and just this year Homeland Security
released a report that I quote though
Mystic violent extremists have developed
credible specific plans to attack
electricity infrastructure since at
least 2020 identifying the electric grid
as a particularly attractive targets End
quotes and yet for some reason the
government is doing everything they can
to downplay these attacks America's
power grid is America's Achilles heel
and if you take a second to put yourself
in the shoes of China or Russia why
wouldn't you have a plan to attack
America's substations why wouldn't you
be sending in sleeper agents to
America's open borders just in case you
decide to attack after all Russia did
have sleeper agents in America as late
as 2010 with the so-called illegals
program so why should we not assume that
there aren't more sleeper agents in
America right now with an obvious Target
being the grid if they get activated but
here's the thing is that Russia might
not even have to go that extreme to
attack the grid
[Music]
thank you
December 23 2015. it's just another
regular afternoon in West Ukraine when
something unexpected happens a worker in
an electrograde substation notices that
his computer's cursor starts moving on
its own the cursor moves across his
homepage clicks on the station's breaker
control panel and then in an instant
shuts down the entire substation nothing
the worker tries to do can stop it and
no matter what the worker tries to do he
can't stop the attack or turn the
station back on and his substation
wasn't the only one across Ukraine
Russian hackers shut down 60 substations
in the span of just a few minutes 230
000 people were left in the dark and
cold and even though the power was only
shut down for a few hours it took
operators months to regain complete
control of their substations but this
could never happen in America right
America is the most modern in the world
country in the world obviously we have
safeguards to protect against this sort
of stuff well not really it turns out
that the control systems for Ukraine's
electric grid are actually more secure
than many in America so if the same
attack happened in the US it would
actually take a lot longer for us to
restore power if we could even restore
it at all and worst of all is that this
attack on Ukraine looks like it was
merely a testing ground for what Russia
has in store for America they are using
Ukraine as basically a testing ground on
shutting power grids down using this
malware we think that's certainly the
case about
2015-2016 this is before the Ukrainian
war
that there were three major cyber
attacks against the Ukraine and there
was conjecture that you know came from
ukrainians that said that uh we were
probably the test case for this about if
our adversaries are currently in the
grid and therefore could shut down our
power grid and she responded
affirmatively so there's something
called
malware or Trojan Horse software and
essentially it could be this malware can
be laying in weight latent and ready to
go to be signaled Senator Angus King you
know had a tirade in a congressional
committee talking about this saying that
we're at war that our adversaries are in
the grid and therefore here we have two
major
public officials responding that this is
a case right now there is no regulated
protection to remove any of this malware
or Trojan Horse software that there or
that they're putting into these
Transformers there's there's literally
no oversight Ukraine is probably less
sensitive than we are because they have
lesser you you know less current uh
technology and more analog technology
and less digital electronics and
therefore that makes you know them a
little bit less vulnerable than our
systems they're more digital and more
advanced Russian malware is likely
already inside America's power grid
which means the exact same thing that
happened in Ukraine in 2015 could happen
in America at a moment's notice it's
that if Russia attacks America it's
going to be a lot worse but that is not
our only threats because it's not just
the Russians that are up in our power
grid it's also China as well
[Music]
foreign
China and Russia are working together
China produces
so 200 Transformers you said it's
actually 300 300 yeah the number 300 300
Transformers come from China what's
really troubling experts say is that
utilities have been buying some of these
critical high voltage Transformers from
China and putting them into our grid
we knew about 300 large Chinese Farmers
that we had imported into the United
States and we knew that at least 200 of
those were embedded in the electric grid
why isn't there a requirement that
somebody checked to see whether it has
some kind of a back door some type of
vulnerability there's no requirement
that you check it Mike maybe calculates
that Chinese Transformers now provide 10
of the electricity provided in New York
City and 20 percent in Las Vegas it's
very simple China makes the cheapest
Transformers and American utility
companies can't resist the prospect of
saving money and while America banned
Chinese telecom companies like Huawei no
one has even bothered to check to see if
these Chinese Transformers are
compromised Transformers are very hard
and expensive to replace but here's the
thing even if China or Russia doesn't
attack the grid good old mother nature
can
thank you foreign
[Music]
we want to get to that disaster in Texas
we certainly do Michael you and I have
family down in Houston and look at this
neighborhood still in darkness more than
620 000 waking up without power in Texas
this morning the concern right now are
these rolling outages these periodic
blackouts that have been going into
effect since early this morning that
leaves up to 2 million Texans without
guaranteed warmth for what looks to be
an incredibly frigid night ahead so
nearly 3 million customers without power
this morning you're looking at live
pictures from Dallas right now one of
the worst power outages in America
actually happened very recently in Texas
in 2021 over 4.5 million people lost
power in the middle of an extreme
snowstorm that caused generators all
over the state to fail for more than a
week residents across the state were
stuck in freezing homes with no
electricity or Heating and within just
four days of the power going out tap
water and most of the affected cities
became undrinkable because the water
treatment plants all ran on good
electricity which meant none of them
could work so unless you had some
emergency water on hand you became
quickly screwed because just as quickly
grocery store shelves were emptied
people's homes burnt down from them
trying to make fires to keep themselves
warm and in hospitals staff rush to get
life support systems up and running on
backup power you started thinking about
like crazy things like whenever you're
cold you know I'm sitting there thinking
about things that I can light on fire in
my living room
it was the first time I I saw how fast
established order could absolutely
disintegrate it brings me tears to even
think about it now
because I lost so much that I can't
replace
there are 46 people died as a direct
result of the storm and power outage and
researchers say that number is severely
under counted and keep in mind all this
Mayhem happened in around 10 days
imagine if the power in your area went
out for just 20 days or 30 days and all
it takes is a cold winter a hot summer a
fire or a flood to set it off just this
year it was warned that the US power
grid is at risk due to extreme heat
expected the summer so who is going to
take down the grid first the Russians
the Chinese domestic terrorists or
Mother Nature herself and once the grid
does go down just exactly how bad will
it gets what would the catastrophic
consequences be at a human level if you
tried to live in a non-electricity world
given the way we build our civilization
nine out of ten of us wouldn't make it
if an attack on the grid resulted in the
power going out staying out for a year
well after you get past the people who
die from not having clean drinking water
for a few weeks then starvation would be
the next big Killer without modern
irrigation and modern Farming tools
there just wouldn't be enough food for
everyone to survive and on hospitals do
have backup generators they don't last
forever so millions of people would soon
die from otherwise preventable diseases
and Medicine life-saving medication like
insulin wouldn't last more than a few
months so when you look at it through
this lens 90 of Americans dying after
just nine months without power doesn't
seem that far-fetched anymore so imagine
what will happen if there is no food no
power and no money and no transportation
for three weeks three months only people
with guns and the boldness to go and
take what they need to survive will live
and here's the thing that you utility
companies that control America's power
grid knows this and yet most of them
aren't doing anything about it
foreign
is there's mostly self-regulation in the
electric utility industry which means so
we call that regulatory capture which
means the utility industry has captured
The Regulators there's ferc and nerc so
I mentioned Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission and then narc North American
electricity and both those entities
especially nerc has 75 percent of their
trustees come from the public utilities
because none of them are legally
required to make upgrades to the Grid or
do anything to protect it from outside
threats these utility companies have
been doing everything they can to avoid
having to make any updates at all that's
because modernizing over 7 000 power
plants and upgrading almost 160 000
miles of high voltage power lines is
extremely expensive it would cost at
least 2.4 trillion dollars just to keep
the power grid running smoothly until
2050 which is a lot of money these
companies don't want to spend they're
not going to spend their hard-earned
money on fixing the power cord just in
case something bad happens why lose out
on billions of dollars now for something
that's probably only going to be a
problem when they're long dead that is
their thinking and you would think that
after the great toilet paper crisis of
coven people will be more open to the
idea of having some emergency food on
hand of maybe having some emergency
water on hand or some kind of emergency
water filter like a life straw not
affiliated or maybe even having a backup
generator on hand with some extra fuel
but no get any of these things and the
average NPC will look at you with
disgust so if you needed that push to
get any of these things you definitely
should and if you want to do something
to help fix this problem this video was
based on a free documentary called grid
down power up thanks to the Sean Ryan
Show and on their website you can watch
the documentary for free and they allow
you to contact your representatives with
a click of a few buttons it takes
literally no work on your part and you
should definitely do it so click the
square on the screen to do it now and
click the card on the screen to watch
the full Sean Ryan interview on this
stay dangerous and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
foreign